by the feeling they have been shattered
last night hearts are still shattering
over Michelle Obama's speech from Monday
I wake up every morning in a house that
was built by slaves and I watched my
daughter's two beautiful intelligent
black young women playing with their
dogs on the White House lawn
well this speech wasn't just a
reflection of her time as first lady
spoke to how far we've come as a nation
but Bill O'Reilly thought he should make
a clarification on a key racial issue
Michelle Obama is essentially correct in
citing slaves as builders of the white
house but there were others working as
well slaves that work there were well
fed and had decent lodgings provided by
the government what your takeaway about
slavery's that they were well fed thank
you Miss all writing for for for
clarifying me about slavery oh oh you
know what's up if and I could read I
sure wants to read the book of how
killing Lincoln cosign allowed to read
seeing is I'm a slave and all but sounds
to me like he did the wrong thing by
feeding them slaves
I go to feed I go free people with the
poor better
see my slave bit is starting to wear off
I don't know what's worse that Bill
O'Reilly Fox blames slavery or that
people all over the internet needed them
to for more we turn to nightly show
contributor Franchesca Ramsey with
another installment of hash it out so
apparently some people are upset that
black people are in the white house and
that some black people built the white
house check out some of these tweets
fact check the white house was not built
by slaves only one-third of the workers
were slaves fact check putting fact
check in front of a bull boat doesn't
make it fact and it's only one third of
the workers were slaves
that means the white house was built by
slaves
that just means only two-thirds of the
workers got to go home at night
that's how fractions work but maybe you
stopped paying attention to fractions
after the three-fifths compromise the
latest didn't build the white house
carpenters did this is gonna blow your
mind
some of the slaves were also carpenters
just like Bill O'Reilly can be a TV
personality and a condescending asshole
the White House was not built solely or
even primarily by slaves who were paid
for work first of all is that a dr. evil
bean this meme is old enough to vote not
solely built by slaves can you please
get out of here with this hashtag all
jobs matter book but I get it you do
these mental gymnastics because it's
uncomfortable to acknowledge this
country was built in part by slaves and
that we benefit from their work but what
else do you think they were doing we
shall overcome isn't a song about how
hard it is to play the banjo and the
worst part if you hadn't been so caught
up on the word slavery you wouldn't
realized that Michelle Obama was saying
something positive yes the White House
was built by slaves which is why it's
such a big deal that we have a black
president if you have a problem with
this then I'm gonna guess it only is
because of who's saying it so let me try
and put this into words that you can
understand
I've a cup every morning
that was built by slaves is that better
no it's not that
you